le deuxième procès de patrick dils
touche à sa fin de ma le verdict sera
rendu aujourd'hui la mère de l'accusé à
dialoguer avec son fils qui hier a eu
des difficultés à expliquer pourquoi il
n'avait pas tué les deux enfants
clément weill-raynal salah à granby
pourquoi patrick dils s'il est innocent
avait il avoué il ya quinze ans le
meurtre de cyril et alexandre 7 jours
d'audience et 1 très longue
interrogatoire hier de l'accusé n'ont
pas permis de répondre à la question les
policiers m'avait suggéré mes aveux a
simplement déclaré patrick dils dont la
personnalité demeure un mystère
à l'époque à 81 parlait pas beaucoup
voir s'il n'y a presque pas là il a
parlé mais c'était largement pas assez
pour convaincre la cour vous espériez
davantage due
patrick on y traverse expérience pas
beaucoup on parle pas alors
il a parlé comme l'a pu avec ses tripes
car malgré tout si aujourd'hui après 15
ans et après la révision qui est femme
historique il ne peut quasiment toujours
pas s'expliqué très clairement sur le
pourquoi les avez la régulation
j'imagine ce que ça pouvait être il ya
quinze ans c'est donc un garçon qui ne
pouvaient pas communiquer et bien qu'il
ait grandi en prison qu'il ait pris une
maturité les experts sont d'accord qui a
toujours beaucoup de mal n'ont pas
communiqué mais a communiqué ses
impressions même si à l'époque le jeune
homme n'avait que 16 ans ses aveux
continuent de peser dans le dossier de
l'accusation
patrick dils avait expliqué en détails
aux policiers puis au juge d'instruction
comment ils avaient massacré à coups de
pierres les deux enfants dont les corps
avaient été retrouvés le long de cette
voie ferrée lors de la reconstitution
il avait répété les gestes ni mais le
double crime dont il est accusé
sans protester de son innocence on n'a
pas d'explication on n'a pas
d'explication
alors on est dans une situation dure
pour la bêtise il faut le reconnaître
parce que là dès qu'on aborde les faits
dès qu'on aborde le dossier
on s'aperçoit que ces déclarations la
semaine terrible terrible au niveau des
fai des déclarations des éléments et
puis terrible si au niveau des détails
qui sont donnés
si patrick dils est innocent qui donc
est le coupable peut être le tueur en
série francis heaulme présents sur les
lieux du crime
mais l'audition de francis heaulme lors
du procès n'a pas permis d'en savoir
plus
c'est donc dans cette salle que tout va
se jouer demain soir à l'issue du
réquisitoire de l'avocat général et des
plaidoiries de la défense patrick dils
dans ce box écoutera les jurés de la
cour d'assises de la marne prononcer
leur verdict coupable ou innocent